europe is home to some of the most
advanced countries
in the world from the united kingdom and
france to germany and
italy but despite this the european
space agency has been quite irrelevant
to the average person for many decades
at this point
at first it was just the world powers
that were outshining them like the ussr
and the united states eventually they
started to include a few developing
countries as well like china
and india today it seems like spacex
and even blue origin are accomplishing
more than the esa
so what in the world happened to the esa
well before we get into the video i
wanted to make it clear that just
because the esa's achievements aren't as
well known
doesn't mean that the esa hasn't
accomplished significant feeds
throughout their lifetime
with that being said let's jump into the
history and accomplishments of the esa
throughout the early 1960s the united
states and the ussr were in a heated
race
to prove the dominance of their
respective political and economical
systems
and one of the manifestations of this
desire was to raise the space
and subsequently the moon given that the
soviet union
and nasa were by far the leaders in the
race many prominent scientists in europe
decided to simply join one side or the
other following world war ii
this not only accelerated the leads of
both the us and the soviet union
but this also significantly reduced the
amount of manpower european countries
had at their disposal
as a result most european countries
quickly realized that they alone could
not even come close to competing against
the leaders
thus when two scientists pier auger and
eduardo amaldi suggested forming a joint
space organization in 1958
several european countries quickly
jumped onto the opportunity
this led to the creation of a commission
dubbed gears in 1960
where representatives from 10 european
countries met up to discuss how exactly
a conglomerate space organization would
work
after two years of debate and discussion
the politicians would agree to provide
eight years of funding for two separate
space organizations
named esro and yaledio esro
or the european space research
organization was established to develop
a spacecraft
meanwhile eldo or the european launch
development organization was established
to develop a launch system
by separating launch development and
spacecraft development
europe hoped that they could accelerate
the development process but
they would soon realize that this wasn't
all that effective
anyways once the two organizations
finally came to life
we would see a slew of new smaller
organizations being created
for instance in 1966 esrin or the
european space research institute
was created to monitor the health of the
earth by launching various environmental
satellites
soon after in 1967 esoc or the european
space operation center would be opened
and this would serve as a control center
for the other organizations
moving on to 1968 estec or the european
space research and technology center
would be opened
to be completely honest i have no clue
why they decided to open so many
different organizations
as many of them seem redundant and
completely unnecessary
fortunately they too soon came to the
same conclusion in 1972
at the time esro had made some decent
progress
but eldo wasn't doing so hot they were
dealing with several technological
problems
cost overruns and political disputes as
a result eldo would be downsized and put
on the back burner in 1972
however it wasn't completely dismantled
quite yet
meanwhile esro would get the opportunity
to work on their first major project in
conjunction with nasa
in 1973 esro and nasa would form an
agreement to work together
esro was tasked with the job of
developing space lab which was a science
module that was supposed to be placed in
space shuttle
in return nasa would allow european
astronauts to join in on their missions
following this agreement esro would
begin construction and testing of the
space lab in 1974
and the space lab would eventually be
used on 25 space shuttle flights between
and 1998 while development of the space
lab was ongoing
we would see further consolidation of
the european space effort
in 1974 eldo would be dismantled and the
remaining resources would be merged with
esro
to create the usa in 1975. that same
year the esa would launch cause b
which was their own first major
scientific research mission cause b
was designed to study cosmic gamma rays
but what made it especially significant
was its longevity
the esa only expected the satellite to
operate for two years but it ended up
working for six years which really
showcased the quality of european space
technology
moving on in 1978 canada would become a
cooperating state to the esa
and the esa would join forces with nasa
and the uk
on another project which was launching
iue
iuv or the international ultraviolet
explorer would become the first high
orbit telescope
and it would be operational for a full
18 years
transitioning into the 1980s we would
see the esa really focused on their own
launch program with the aureon program
the ariane program started to take shape
after the dismantling of eldo
but since it got defunded in 1974 the
europeans had to come up with a new
launch system
which led them to the ariane program the
first orion launch would take place in
and it would serve as a solid commercial
launch vehicle throughout the 1980s
aryan 1 wasn't reusable like the space
shuttle but considering that the space
shuttle cost so much reuse in the first
place
aryan 1 wasn't that behind economically
anyways
moreover the esa would consistently
update the arian rocket throughout the
80s to make it more reliable
and cost effective by 1988 the esa would
come up with the ariane 4 which would
complete missions between 1988 and 2003
and this rocket is really what would
establish the esa as a leading space
organization
aside from this throughout the 1980s and
1990s
the esa would also work on one more
major program which was the hermes
spacecraft
the irma spacecraft was designed to be
the esa's first crewed launch vehicle
and it was slated to be able to carry
four to six astronauts into orbit
originally it was planned to be launched
with the ariane 4 rocket
but the irma spacecraft would quickly
become too heavy for the ariane ford to
handle
so dsa was on developing the ariane 5
which was expected to allow the esa to
complete crude missions
into space however the challenger
disaster would really put a halt
on these plans you see nasa was on a
great run throughout the 1960s
and 70s and this really built up some
confidence around space flight
i mean apollo 13 literally went wrong in
the middle of space
and nasa was still able to bring back
the crew safely but
the challenger disaster really grounded
how dangerous space flight
really was and that things could still
go wrong despite the smartest minds in
the world working on making things go
right
as a result several additional safety
precautions would be introduced
after the disaster accounting for these
new safety precautions added significant
weight onto hermes
which forced the esa to produce a crew
capacity to three astronauts
even with these reductions though hermes
was expected to weigh 21 000 kilograms
which would really push the limits of
the ariane 5 rocket
this obstacle along with the variety of
other delays and cost overruns
eventually resulted in our main
spacecraft being cancelled in 1992
and finally that brings us into the
esa's final major project which is mars
express
as the name suggests mars express was a
mission to mars in 2003
during the mission the usa successfully
landed beagle 2 onto the surface of mars
which marked the first full european
mission to any planet
just two years later the sa would land
the hygens probe on the surface of titan
which was the first landing ever in the
outer solar system
since then the esa has made significant
contributions to the iss
and sent several astronauts to the space
station with the help of nasa
so as you can see the usa does have a
pretty rich history
and we just scratch the surface of their
contributions and accomplishments
but then why is the esa so irrelevant in
the public eye
well i think there are two very simple
reasons for this with the first being a
lack of place
when it comes to space organizations
there are a few very clear sectors
first we have the developed space
leaders which are of course the us
and russia next we have the developing
space contenders which include countries
like china
and india and finally we have the
private space competitors like spacex
and blue origin but the esa doesn't
really fit into any of these categories
the esa is of course not on the level of
nasa or ross cosmos
but at the same time it doesn't really
make sense to compare them with china
or india you have to keep in mind that a
lot of the countries involved in the esa
are some of the most developed countries
in the world
meanwhile china and india are still very
much developing countries
so it's not really fair to compare them
with the esa
as for the private space industry the
usa is not private
so that completely disqualifies them
from that category
as a result the esa doesn't really have
a clear ranking within the space
hierarchy
their accomplishments are more
comparable to that of developing
countries
but european countries are actually
developed countries
so the sa is kind of just lost in space
the other major reason that the average
person doesn't really care about the usa
is because the esa has not completed a
crew mission and they have no plans to
do one in the minute future
either sending probes and rovers into
space and other planets are great feats
but food missions are really what get
the masses interested whether that be to
the iss
the moon or mars take spacex for
instance
space enthusiasts have been excited
about spacex for several years at this
point
however the event that really garnered
the attention of the masses was getting
astronauts to the iss
considering that the usa has mostly
played a background role throughout
their lifetime
it's not too surprising that the average
person is not too interested
but don't let the lack of attention for
you the european space agency
is not actually relevant by any means
when it comes to space
technology why do you guys think the esa
is so underrated
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys think the esa deserves more
credit
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one